Week five of our baking marathon and Ian is way out front.
He set a cracking pace and is now pulling away from the pack
with an amazing three out of four Star Baker titles to his credit.
I can't wait to wrap him in a foil cape and give him a good rub down.
- Welcome... BOTH:
- To the Great British Bake Off.
Last week, Ian triumphed with desserts.
That is sheer heaven on a plate.
It was Sandy who failed to meet the mark...
It's raw underneath.
..becoming the fourth baker to leave the tent.
- Come on, let's cover her.
- Bring it in.
I'm OK.
So far, the bakers have also been tested on cakes...
Whoa!
..biscuits...
Happy with that.
..and breads.
Ta-dah!
But now how will they cope without some basic ingredients?
What?
It's definitely going to be a good one.
Cake without sugar...
I'm worried that it might be too simple.
..bread without gluten...
This...is...rank.
..and an ice cream roll without diary.
Might that stop it setting?
I hope it won't.
A good sponge, but where's the ice cream?
Ice cream, anyone?
That was intense.
Imagine a world of cake without sugar,
bread without gluten,
Mel without Sue.
Huh?
That's 27 years of my life!
It's free-from week.
(Finally got rid of her.)
SHEEP BLEAT
It's been amazing to be at the front like this for the last three weeks.
All the other bakers want to break my fingers,
but, you know, that's something they've got to live with, I guess.
I feel a bit embarrassed for the rest of us. I'm like,
"Someone's got to give him a bit of competition,"
"otherwise it makes us look a bit pants."
Would I love to knock him off the top?
Absolutely! Who wouldn't?
Everybody wants to knock him off the top spot.
Watch out, Ian!
Morning, bakers.
Now, for your Signature Bake,
Paul and Mary would like you to bake a cake.
But you can't use sugar, OK?
You can use honey, fruit - but nothing that comes from a bag.
It can be any shape, size or flavour that you desire.
Two-and-a-half hours on the bake.
On your marks.
Get set. Bake!
I think we're looking for something
that's as close to a regular cake as possible.
I want it to be as light and tasty, and fluffy, as possible.
It's just a bit harder.
It's something different I'm trying.
I loved it when I tried it and I'm going for it.
So, I have made sugar-free cakes before in the past,
so I feel OK with the sugar-free, yeah.
Dare I say it?
When you're baking a cake,
one of the most important ingredients is sugar
and we're asking them to forget about sugar,
and use anything else to sweeten it -
and most of them will be using a form of syrup.
Some of our bakers will add fruits to get that sweetness.
When you think of adding a fruit,
you may think apple, you may think pear...
The problem with that - they don't carry too much flavour.
You need something a bit more robust LIKE an orange, LIKE a lemon.
Something that will override the sponge and give it a flavour.
Morning, Paul.
Hello, Ian. Morning, Star Baker.
I know. It's, kind of, strange days, eh?
Right, tell us all about your cake.
I'm doing... Well, it's pear, ginger and honey cake.
So, the total sweetener is honey?
It's just honey, yeah. That's all it is.
To his honey and pear batter,
Ian is also adding root ginger for heat
and chopped walnuts to give it some bite.
Have you had any problems with the texture?
Some of the first ones did turn out
a little bit moist and a bit heavy.
Sometimes honey cakes are quite dense but a lovely flavour,
and there's lots going in there, I might say.
Oh, yes, a hearty amount.
- Thank you, Ian.
- See you later.
- Thank you.
- Good morning, Mat.
- Morning.
- Hello.
So, Mat, what's the cake you've chosen?
And what have you got as your sweetener?
OK, so I've gone for a carrot cake,
so I'm using - instead of the sugar - dates and honey.
- Good choice.
- Right.
In addition to honey and dates,
Mat's carrot cake will be packed with raisins
and flavoured with cinnamon, ginger and orange zest.
There's a lot of filling in there?
- Yeah.
- God, that's a monster.
What could happen, if the mixture's too slack,
the fruit could go to the bottom
because it will be pretty wet.
- Good luck, Mat.
- Thank you very much. Cheers.
Mat's not the only one
who has adapted their trusty carrot cake recipe
to make it sugar-free.
Sometimes it's gone wrong, sometimes it's gone right
and I think I've got the balance just right.
Obviously, that'll be dependent on the judges.
Paul's sugar substitute is agave nectar -
a natural syrup that comes from a cactus-like plant.
For extra sweetness, he's adding sultanas
and for texture, chopped pecan nuts.
To come out with the look, the texture and the flavour
is a bit of a skill, a bit of an art,
and it's definitely chemistry as well -
something I was never good at in school.
I'm a firm believer in the all-in-one method
but, this one, there's just too many variables
that are different from your standard...
butter, sugar, flour and eggs.
Well, originally, I'd done a normal, sort of, cake recipe
and it didn't work because it was too liquid.
So, I decided, instead, I'd do a genoise sponge...
and incorporate the eggs and the molasses
till they're quite airy and then add the flour,
and so we're relying completely on the air in this to make it go up.
The mixture seems all right. The same as it looks at home so,
happy so far, yeah.
So, I am making a polenta cake
with grapefruit zest and grapefruit juice.
So, I'm making a syrup with the grapefruit juice,
injecting that into the cake with some syringes.
Tamal will add honey to his grapefruit syrup
which will be applied to his polenta cake, once baked.
He's also using honey as his sugar substitute.
I can't wait to see what this tastes like
and then obviously the texture that polenta brings as well.
A good polenta cake is worth having.
Let's hope your is one of the good ones.
- I hope it's a good one. Thank you.
- Thanks.
I'm making a pineapple upside down cake.
A simple classic.
Alvin knows his pineapple upside down cake inside out.
He's replaced the refined sugar with agave nectar.
It's my go-to...
and this is something I'm comfortable baking.
It's a quick bake, 45 minutes in the oven.
I hope it's good enough.
Just trying to get it reasonably equal
so they bake at the same, sort of, speed.
Good morning.
Hello, tell us all about your cake.
Today, I went for, not only sugar-free,
I went for gluten-free as well.
- Hello!
- I'm using...
quinoa flour, almond flour and hazelnut flour.
Ugne's using her alternative flours
to make chocolate and vanilla cakes,
which she too has sweetened with agave nectar.
She'll assemble them in chequered layers
before decorating with hazelnut butter icing.
I'm going to frost it with a little purplish colour
and I might do some truffles as well.
You might put some truffles on there?
I would, because I don't think it screams,
"Hello, I'm a cake," enough.
They want to go in for...30 minutes.
I am putting them in the oven for half an hour.
While the sponge bakes,
Flora and Nadiya are making sugar-free fillings for their cakes.
- Good morning, Nadiya.
- Morning.
Right. what are you up to?
So, I am making a very healthy no-cook blueberry jam.
- How do you do it?
- Well, I use basil seeds.
When they touch liquid, they bloom
and that will create the jam-like texture
without all the sugar in it.
I'm fascinated by this.
- I can't wait to try that.
- Yeah.
Nadiya's blueberry jam will be used to sandwich together
her blueberry and caraway seed cakes.
For her sweetener, she's used mulberry molasses.
I tried this cake out on my father-in-law
and he said it was perfect so, hoping they like it.
These are Bramley apples
and I'm just making a compote to put inside the cake.
A filling that's a bit jam-like but sugar-free.
Flora's apple compote will be spread
between her pistachio and cardamom flavoured cakes.
She'll decorate with mascarpone icing
and more sugar-free cakes.
I'm making my honey madeleines
which will go around the base of the cake.
Something else to do, but I don't know how long we've got.
I'm probably going to regret adding something else to my long list.
Bit longer.
- Definitely not.
- I've got the fear.
Cake fear.
I can't, almost, tell whether it's burning or if it's just...
Hopefully, it's not burning, it's just the molasses.
I'm not taking my eye off the ball. Not on this.
Spot on.
They're good, they'll do.
It looks how it normally looks,
which is quite a relief.
I'm pleased.
I'm happy with that, very happy with it.
So, it's 50% grapefruit juice,
50% blood orange juice
and then some honey as well.
So, it's not 50% of the others.
Ah, maths.
So, that is the majority of the bake done, really.
Now I've got to start working on the sort of decoration side of it.
Alvin's glazing with agave syrup,
everyone else is making a soft cheese icing.
This is my mascarpone and cream cheese icing.
Obviously, I'm going to add a liquid sweetener to it
rather than icing sugar.
So, by squeezing a lot of the water out of the cream cheese,
I get a denser consistency that I can spread around the cake.
Little bit more honey in there.
I'm just making mascarpone cream with maple syrup.
I'm going to sweeten with agave.
So, I've swapped icing sugar for honey.
That's maple syrup I've put in there.
As you can see, I've still got a nice, good, thick consistency there.
I'm finished. I'm done.
Is that good?
- Yeah.
- Too simple, probably.
Oh, dear.
30 minutes, bakers. Just 30 minutes remaining.
I'm waiting for my cakes to cool down.
What's everyone else doing?
I'm doing whatever you're doing, Ian.
The cake's a bit...
It's not as soft as I wanted it to be.
Everyone's working.
I'm worried that it might be too simple.
I'm going to mix and match the colours of the sponge,
and when you cut into cake, it should have like,
check effect in the middle of the cake.
If you play it safe it will be boring.
We can do boring every day,
but it's not everyday bake,
it's Bake Off.
Paul, you're prowling.
I am prowling, yes.
You're slightly... You're on the old...
Are you thinking in term of,
"Right...who's my competition?"
Well, the competition is Ian, I think.
But it could go wrong for him at any time.
Slightly hoping.
Let's do it.
Five minutes, done.
I'm not sugar-coating it.
Tried to fix it, but we'll see.
Oh, no. What's happened?
The top went because my top layer broke.
Oh, well.
That is one ugly looking cake.
Bakers, time is now up...
..so move all your bakes to the end of the bench.
It does look very pretty.
The bake is good.
The sharpness that you get from the grapefruit is beautiful.
It's such a delicate cake, actually.
Really well done.
Polenta is quite difficult
- but I enjoyed that cake.
- OK.
- Congratulations.
- Well done.
- Thank you.
- Well done, Tamal.
It looks beautifully finished.
Very, very simple.
Maybe a little bit too simple.
Cuts well.
And this has got pears in?
This has got pears in, yes.
The actual cake itself
- is not sweet enough.
- Right.
But push it with the icing, it improves it greatly.
Pear's not going to bring anything to a party in an unsweetened cake.
- Yeah.
- I think it was the wrong choice.
It just looks like it hasn't been baked.
Looks a bit like Christmas pudding.
- MEL: Yeah.
- It does.
OK.
- I actually really like it.
- Right.
- I think it is baked.
- Yep.
I just think you're got so much stuff in there
that the lack of sugar is almost incidental.
I think you've made a really nice cake.
- Thank you.
- Nice one.
- Cheers.
I mean, it's got a great flavour.
It's probably slightly overdone.
I think you've got superb icing.
You've been able to do that nice ribbing round the side
- and that, with cream cheese, is quite difficult.
- Yes.
You've made yourself extra challenges
that we didn't ask for.
- I mean, you haven't got a classic flour in there and...
- Yeah.
..I think that's why the texture doesn't hold together.
MEL: Oh, wow.
The chocolate part is very, very close textured
and tastes a little bit bitter.
The hazelnut cream is stunning,
however the look of it...
needs a bit more work.
- What about these flowers, edible?
- Nope.
Spit it out.
I think the blueberry jam,
that you made, using those basil seeds, is beautiful.
I love the appearance
but, sadly, the genoise is just dry top and bottom.
I think it's just slightly overbaked but the flavours are spot-on...
and quite daring flavours, too.
- Well done.
- Thank you.
I think the whole thing looks really good.
I just think there's too much moisture in the cake,
which makes it feel like it's underbaked.
You've got such a pretty design
but the cake is just stodgy.
I just think the apple was a bad choice.
That is superb.
The sweetness is perfect for me.
- The syrup's soaking through.
- Yeah.
I think you've done really well
- considering there's no sugar in there.
- Yeah.
As soon as you get the pineapple with the sponge,
it's a perfect balance.
- And you've made a cracking cake.
- Wow, thank you so much.
- Thank you, Alvin.
- Well done, Alvin.
- Thank you very much, sir.
Wow.
Such a good feeling, such a good feeling.
And I wish it could be like that all the time. I wish.
I tried to do something different.
It didn't work for them.
Paul didn't like the pears at all.
I didn't think they were that offensive but, clearly, he did.
After a sugar-free morning,
the bakers must now find the energy for their next challenge.
The technical.
Bakers, if you thought making sugar-free cakes was easy,
you are going to love this afternoon's technical challenge.
It's one of Paul's recipes and,
like Paul himself,
it defines simple.
Paul and Mary, I'm afraid you, you can't watch this one
so if you could just vacate.
Be good now, you two.
So, Paul and Mary would love you please
to make 12 identical
gluten-free pittas.
Oh, that just got me.
Simple process, simple ingredients
but - oh, my days - tricky to make.
You've got two hours.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
BOTH: Bake!
I have never made gluten-free bread in my life,
not talking about pittas.
I know what a pitta looks like,
so at least I've got something to work towards in my head.
What?
It's definitely going to be a good one.
What the hell?
Why did you choose pitta bread as the gluten-free challenge?
What we're testing them on is their base knowledge
of gluten-free flours.
The right consistency is almost like a sticky dough,
rather than a wet dough.
OK, come on. Let's have a go.
That's a beautiful shape too and
it's just got that tinge of brown.
That's right.
Now, if you just tear it, it's not glutinous,
where you get a stretch.
It breaks fairly easily, you know?
Then you get that pocket.
I think they're really rather good.
It's almost as good as traditional pitta with wheat flour.
Well, it seems to me that,
not only do they have a new technique to get used to,
I think many of them will never have made anything
gluten-free unless they've been particularly asked to.
I agree, and now they've been asked to.
I have never made pitta bread before so,
I don't know if whatever that...
is to do with a pitta bread
or to with the fact that it's gluten-free.
Everyone's been given a packet of brown powder.
I don't even know what it is.
"Fisilum."
"Fislium."
It's no good if you can't even read it, is it?
When mixed with water,
psyllium powder can act as the gluten substitute for bread.
It's like a fibre
and it's really gelatinous
when it's mixed with water.
This...is...rank.
Doesn't smell particularly nice either.
"Using all the ingredients, make a dough."
"Put the flour in, yeast one side of the bowl."
Obviously keep it separate from the salt because it reacts with it.
I've never made any gluten-free bread before.
So, this is really new for me.
It's really soft and it's really wet.
I think it's meant to be very sticky.
Difficult to...
..work with.
I mean, can you knead a liquid?
I think I need a bit more flour, maybe. This is...
This is bad news, innit?
Very loose dough.
I've got big lumps of that powered stuff.
You're not going to stretch any gluten strands
cos there's no gluten in it.
So, I'm just mixing it, basically.
I'm not going to work it any more longer,
I did around ten, 15 minutes so far, so...
..I think that should be about enough.
It's coming together a little bit.
Do you eat pitta, if not make them?
- Once.
- You've eaten one once?
- Yeah.
What was your memory of it?
Can you remember what it looked like?
Like a triangle?
It's more important to get it proved than kneaded.
I decided to start proving it
because it wasn't changing, even remotely.
I'm sure that'll be a wrong decision.
Ideally, anything needs to be proved for a good hour
or till it's, at least, doubled in size.
- Obviously, the longer the better.
- I'll give it 40 to 45 minutes
and then I'll go into shaping mode,
I think.
- What shape are you doing?
- Eh?
Circle, triangle?
Oh, don't even know.
The more I work this,
it doesn't seem to be changing.
So, I'm, kind of, thinking I might just pop it in to prove.
Definitely won't be coming number one.
Fine, whatever.
OK, bakers, you've got an hour
till we want to hear
the "pitta-patter" of tiny breads
coming up to the table.
I've got nine minutes left on the prove now.
It's just, I've got nine minutes to decide how to bake them now.
That's not a long time.
At least half an hour to prove, I think,
but, ideally, I'd want longer than that.
Damn.
Worried about this one.
I think I'm one of the first to take it out.
The plan was one hour...
but...
..I'm going to start.
It doubled the size so, I think that's what I need.
Oh, that's so sticky.
OK, that's really weird.
So, I'm trying to do it equally into 12.
So, a little bit of maths and maths isn't my strong point.
I'm going to do it into three, first of all,
and then divide each three into quarters.
Very nervous, actually.
I don't like not being in the know this much
and I think I've got a lot riding on this.
So, they're oval like rugby ball type shape,
but you can get little ones as well.
I'm confused with a naan bread and a pitta.
Are they the same?
But I'm assuming, judging by the amount of dough we've got,
they need to be big ones.
I'm going to go for oblong, circle...
Going to go for oblong.
I mean, it's risen a bit,
so I'm pleased about that.
Happy is quite a big word to be using
for something that looks like this.
Trying to make them look fairly similar but...
They're, sort of, OK.
This is not turning out good.
Bakers, I have PITTA for you, but there's only 30 minutes left.
What?
Cook, pittas, cook.
Just put my first lot in.
Don't think they need proving again.
I'm sure they don't need proving again.
I'm giving it 15 minutes.
Hopefully, it will be enough.
Are you running out of time?
Yeah, a little bit. I think...
You've got 23 minutes and you're telling me you want to do
a final prove and then bake them and they take 20 minutes -
which means you've got three minutes to prove them.
Well, when you put it like that, it sounds stupid.
These are hollow - so, yeah, that's good.
They were in for 12 minutes.
I've had to take them out to get the next six in but...
I don't think they're going to be nice inside.
I've just got that gut feeling.
- It's just funny how little colour they're getting.
- Yeah.
I'd like a nice bit of brown to it,
but it's just...
Grey and dense.
They're meant to puff up.
There's one or two that are, there's ones that aren't.
They're puffing up all right.
I'm not sure if I'm supposed to do that,
but I'd rather have both sides evenly baked.
Bakers, don't be in a PITTA despair,
because it's over in five minutes.
- What?
- Five minutes to go.
I always think I'm going to come last,
but I'm not looking around right now.
Let's just see...
how it goes.
Let's just say, this has not been my favourite technical.
OK, bakers, time is up.
Finishing dusting down your pitta
and pop them on the gingham altar behind the photo of yourself.
Mary and Paul, if you'd like to join us.
Right, what we're looking for is 12 baked pittas,
nice and thin with an envelope inside.
Now, they are identical.
Nice and thin.
Can we get a pocket? We can.
See, this one's got a bit of colour on it
and has naturally formed a pocket -
but the ones without colour remain doughy.
Now, they are baked but they're just not thin enough...
so you're not getting too much of an envelope.
You can't open it up.
Now, moving on.
- It's doughy.
- Yeah.
It tastes all right.
I would take that as a flatbread than a pitta.
Now, these have got a bit more colour on them.
Uniform, decent shape.
Maybe too thick to get an envelope but... Cos it hasn't formed.
I've got a bit of an envelope there.
Yeah, but that's not a natural one.
No, I've worked my little fingers along it.
LAUGHTER
- Right.
- What about these?
These are round, aren't they?
Yeah, quite a lot of flour on there.
It's gone very light.
This is someone who knows how to do bread
but, unfortunately, they don't know how to do pitta bread.
Now moving on.
This looks more like it, actually. Nice colour.
There it is.
Gosh, there's room for all sorts of things in there.
That came as a proper pocket.
Half of them are pretty good, very good.
The other half, just a little bit thinner
and a little bit longer in the oven.
Oh, look, we're getting a good... Look at that.
- You got a pocket in there.
- They're good.
They could have just stayed in a little bit longer.
But they're not bad at all.
- Quite uniform as well.
- And the flavour was good.
- Yes.
Very bread-like. Out of all of them, that's the thickest one.
That's lovely at that end but,
here, it's very doughy at the bottom half.
But whose gluten-free pitta is technically perfect?
So, in eighth place, who's that?
They were not quite done and it was the thickest of all of them.
And in seventh place is this one.
Very thick. Couldn't get any envelopes in there at all,
it was more like a bread, too much flour.
Ugne is sixth,
Ian - fifth, and Mat is fourth.
And in third place is this one.
Nice and thin, which was good.
You had a pocket in places.
And in second place...
Now, these were getting good.
They had a nice colour
and we could get a pocket in there.
And in first place...
That's me.
APPLAUSE
How many times have you struggled
with technical challenges over the weeks?
And then you come straight up and get first.
Well done.
Ha-ha, I got first in the technical.
Three good weeks and now, I'm thinking,
"Right, OK. This is a bit nerve-racking.
"I've got to do some work tomorrow."
It could have gone better...
..but it could have been worse.
Yeah.
Just terrible, really, wasn't it?
So, Paul and Mary, Ian started this weekend riding high
with his three Star Bakers.
Didn't go so well for him yesterday, did it?
I don't think it did.
In his Signature Challenge, the bake was OK,
but he was always going to struggle with the pear.
And in the technical, he came fifth.
Ugne.
MARY: She was just putting everything into her chocolate cake.
- And then it, gradually, was falling apart, wasn't it?
- Hmm.
MEL: Who do you think's in trouble?
I think Ugne and, dare I say, Ian.
- Ooh, that would be a shocker!
- MEL WHISTLES
Morning, bakers.
Hope you're wearing your sequined undergarments
because it is Showstopper day.
Now, Paul and Mary would love you to make an evergreen
of the chest freezer.
It's the ice cream roll.
Now, what we're looking for is silky smooth ice cream,
covered in luxurious sticky jam
and then some light, golden sponge wrapped around that...
BUT - and there's always a but -
it's got to be dairy-free ice cream,
so I'm afraid you will not be able to milk any goats,
sheep, pigs or cats for this challenge.
You've got four-and-a-half hours on the Showstopper clock, bakers.
- On your marks...
- Get set...
- Bake!
I've made this four times as a practice but...
Cos I always make the ordinary ice cream
using heavy cream, you know.
But not this...surprisingly.
Of many times I made it, it never failed -
but you know me, I made many times, at home, stuff which failed me here.
I feel like I got something to prove today
after what happened with the technical yesterday.
No pressure...but it has to go well.
We're really throwing it at them.
I mean, first of all, they've got to do their dairy-free ice cream -
which is very tricky.
They've got to make a perfect sponge,
wonderful jam and the whole thing
has got to look outstanding.
We expect to see magic in the tent.
We're not going to hold back on them and judge them thinking,
"Oh, well they used an alternative ice cream therefore that'll do."
"That'll do" baking in that tent, in a Showstopper,
is not good enough.
With a dairy ban in force,
the tent is taking on a rather tropical aroma.
I'm making ice cream using coconut milk.
I'm using coconut milk.
The coconut milk is, kind of, fairly strong coconut flavour.
This is coconut syrup,
so it's coconut milk with sugar.
Boil it down till it's quite thick.
In here, we've got the coconut custard mix.
If you don't heat it up, then it'd be quite thin.
I'm just looking at it cos I don't want it to be curdled.
So, you want to thicken it up a little bit - but not too much,
otherwise you end up with scrambled eggs.
So... It's not, it's fine.
It's just the foam at the top that's making me panic a little bit.
- Good morning, Alvin.
- Good morning, Sir. Morning, Mary.
Morning, Alvin.
Ice cream roll. Tell us about yours.
I've chosen a classic Filipino flavour.
This is a staple ice cream back home in the Philippines
which is Buko Pandan.
So, basically, the "Buko" translates to "the young coconut meat,"
and we use it like our vanilla in here.
- We use it in south east Asia like that.
- It's like sun cream.
Please, rub some on him, please.
- That's what he's been using all this time.
- Exactly.
Alvin's Buko Pandan coconut-flavoured ice cream
will be surrounded by mango and passion fruit jam
and a fatless sponge.
His children love it -
especially the vibrant ice cream.
- Mary, have I got a green tongue?
- Yes, you have.
Does that go?
MARY: No, you're there forever.
It's quite strong.
Look away.
- Eyes front.
- All right.
Tell us all about your ice cream roll.
It's mango, lime and coconut ice cream
and a sponge decorated with
a pattern of a desert island.
Paul's almond-based sponge will be spread with pineapple jam
before adding his ice cream.
The centrepiece will be a fondant bikini-clad sunbather.
I've got, like, a beach towel on the top.
I've then got palm trees coming up round the side,
it will then sit on sand, which is sugar,
and then, obviously, blue piping to replicate the water.
Wow, is there room for three more on your desert island?
I'd quite like to go there.
It's a tropical ice cream roll,
which I thought was very original -
but I've looked around and it's maybe not as original.
So, it's a passion fruit ice cream,
a pineapple jam
and then the sponge is just a simple fatless sponge.
Tamal will bake a lattice pattern into his sponge,
which he'll flavour with lemon.
He'll top his ice cream roll with Italian meringue
and a crafty creation.
And I've made this baby bunting thing
that I made on train on the way down
which I've, sort of, being umming and ahhing
about whether or not I should use it
and now I'm like, "No, I need, I need every little thing."
OK, so today, I'm making a coconut ice cream
with raspberry jam and
just a fatless sponge.
Mat will roll his sponge like a Swiss roll
and he's going for a minimalist look.
So, your only decoration is the stripes.
I'm not saying, you know, that's bad.
- So, you're using stripes...
- Yeah.
- ..then plain raspberry jam...
- It is.
- ..and then ice cream?
- Yeah.
You're...trying to frighten him.
- You're being tough.
- I'm not. There's nothing wrong with using plain stuff
but when you go back to the basics,
- the basics have got to be good.
- Right.
Oh, I can smell her peanut butter from here.
- That smells so nice.
- Can you smell it?
Yeah, it's really good.
- Good morning, Ugne.
- Good morning.
Right, can you tell us all about your ice cream roll?
My ice cream will be peanut butter ice cream.
- I'm going to make it with a grape jelly.
- Grape?
Grape jelly and peanut butter's the best combination.
Ugne is shunning convention
and will spread her grape jelly jam
in the centre of her peanut butter ice cream
rather than on her sponge, which will be flavoured with chocolate.
I mean, it sounds interesting.
Not convinced, totally, about the flavour combinations.
- You never do.
- No.
I need this to work today.
- Good luck.
- Thank you.
It's quite a thick custard.
The ice cream will only freeze in time
if they've struck the fine balance
between coconut, fats and flavourings.
I'm making a chocolate ice cream.
Very nearly went for a tropical theme, which I'm glad I didn't.
This is coconut ice cream.
I made it at home and it set,
so I really hope it sets today.
So, I've got the ice cream, itself, chilling in there now
and here we've got my two, sort of, "boats" I'm calling them.
Each half is going to be filled with ice cream
and then once that's all chilled and assembled,
pop the two halves together and roll it up.
Ian hopes his moulds will shape his mango and stem ginger ice cream
into a perfect round to form the centre of his "dessert" island.
Complete with caramel palm trees
and chocolate marzipan coconuts.
There is another desert island.
- There is.
- How do you feel about that?
Well...
- ..he hasn't got that.
- Yep.
The ice cream is still quite...
..liquidy.
Didn't quite get the flavour that I want.
I better add another half teaspoon.
It looks like it's, sort of...
setting.
It's looking a bit...bubbly.
I am making a pear and chocolate,
and macadamia nut, ice cream buche,
so there isn't a roll as such...
..which is my concern.
Flora's buche will be assembled in a mould.
She'll create layers of vanilla ice cream, pear jam,
caramelised pears and macadamia nuts inside a thin chocolate sponge.
If it goes to plan, it will be lovely
but it hasn't ever gone to plan before so...
I'm not optimistic.
Ian and Nadiya have set themselves an extra challenge -
to create an additional frozen element
to go inside the ice cream.
This is my strawberry and lime mousse.
I don't know if anybody's doing a mousse...
but it worked for me at home
and I'm just hoping it works for me here.
Nadiya's ice cream mousse will run through her chocolate ice cream.
She'll wrap it in a sponge with a henna-inspired design.
Yeah. Happy with that.
I'm just going to leave it in the freezer,
just because I can't leave it out or it'll get too runny.
Just a little bit of mango sauce in there
which we freeze like that
and hopefully, at the end, we just...
and that will be the core of the ice cream roll.
So, in the freezer it goes.
Mary and Paul are expecting a show-stopping sponge.
Six of the bakers are inlaying designs.
I will freeze it and then I'll pour Swiss roll batter over it.
When it bakes, this pattern should be left on the sponge
Is this helping?
That always helps.
I love it when there's a Sue hanging above my head.
Hey.
As the designs set,
they move onto making a fatless sponge -
which they must be able to manipulate without it cracking.
I made it a few times.
Well, maybe like three times, the sponge itself,
and it's been OK.
Well, it's quite sort of light and fluffy, which is what you want,
but it's still quite reasonably robust to roll.
I'm very aware that everyone else is doing a lot more
design and decorative stuff so...
Yeah, I dunno. Fingers crossed.
This is one of the desserts
that the flaws are so obvious if you get something wrong.
If it's too thick in places, it tends to crack a little bit -
which is what I don't want.
The challenge, when cooking a sponge to roll,
is judging the moment when it's cooked through
but still has the flexibility.
Are you enjoying this, Ian? Is this going OK?
I think it's going OK.
I, kind of, feel like I need to do a good job today.
Are you feeling the pressure?
Yeah, I was quite relaxed the last couple of weeks...
- Yeah.
- ..at this point. This week I've got to fight a bit harder.
So, what are you doing to sort of...?
I was hoping to do a few extra twiddly bits
- but I don't think I'll get time to do those.
- Come on,
- you can do the twiddly bits, Ian.
- Twiddly bits, hmm.
- Come on.
So, it's had 10 minutes now.
It's quite nice and brown on top.
I think I'll give it another couple of minutes.
I'd like it a bit browner, you know.
Just give it another minute, I reckon.
Ah, baby.
That's going to do me.
Yeah, it's done.
Peeling away.
That looks quite nice.
Ahh, it smells nice.
So, that just needs to cool,
for me to not...
do something to it.
It's quite crispy.
Might a left it in a bit long.
Roll up, roll up.
Bakers, you've got one hour to complete your diary-free creations.
One hour.
OK.
So, the paddle's stuck, which means...
it's churned.
Now, just to get it out.
Yum.
I pleased with this.
See, it's far too runny.
It looks OK.
I think the consistency's all right. It's almost spreadable -
which is what I want when I make the roll, you know.
I've got my tubes.
So, basically, by dividing the ice cream up into two halves,
hopefully, it should chill down quite a lot quicker.
I just need to roll it into a log now.
Let it set completely in the freezer.
Slightly worried, yes. Who wouldn't be?
Who wants an ice cream roll with slop out of the side?
Bakers, you've got half an hour left to roll and freeze.
Ooh.
- TAMAL:
- Don't mind us.
MAT AND TAMAL CHEER
- NADIYA:
- Oh, he's clever.
I have to work really quickly.
because everything stars to melt really fast, so...
got to keep going.
I'm just trying to get a really, really fine sponge on the outside...
because I've just found that it helps ice cream freeze
and because there's so much going in terms of filling...
..I think a finer sponge is just a bit nicer.
The jam should neatly bind the sponge to the ice cream.
So relieved to see this is nice and frozen,
just how I wanted it to.
Seems to be nice and solid.
This has jam inside the ice cream. See?
- It's INSIDE the ice cream?!
- Yeah.
Might that stop it setting?
I hope it won't.
Cos most people have ice cream within jam,
but you've gone the other way.
Mary and Paul are expecting a perfect round of ice cream
contained and sealed by the sponge.
Ice cream is too big, I think.
It is too big.
Do you want a hand, Alvin?
- Yes, please.
- What do you want me to do?
Just want to cut this half away.
- It's not going to go in, is it?
- It's not going to go.
Oh, that's full.
It's a bit like me trying to get my trousers on every morning.
OK. That's it.
Yes.
(Oh, no.)
(Damn.)
Sponge cracked.
I'm going to put this back in the freezer.
The ice cream has just one more chance to freeze up
before judging.
Yep, that's really cold.
Then just close it...
and hope for the best.
You're looking very concerned.
It's the ice cream.
Ice cream, anyone?
That was intense.
No show-stopping ice cream roll would be complete
without show-stopping decoration.
I've never watched a man,
particularly someone of your stature,
turn a calf...
quite as marvellously as the way you turn that.
Killer hands.
That's good to know.
My hands are shaking more than I would like,
- so it's not exactly a straight line.
- Looks slightly scary, doesn't it?
Making palm fronds with it.
I love these hanging nuts.
I had to put three on there for obvious reasons, yes.
You need a gusset, Paul, that's going to be a...
Bit of a loincloth going on.
Yes, we can't have her going out on the beach like that,
she'll get arrested. HE LAUGHS
An island.
This is just a large block of Parmesan.
Parmesan? That would be interesting wouldn't it?
I can't remember what it's called.
Marzipan! Marzipan. Yes.
It's the gusset. HE LAUGHS
No that's bad, that's bad.
That's better.
- Is that better?
- Yeah, that's much better. Legs together.
- I think you should leave her alone.
- No, no. That's all...
All good, all encased, all safe.
Now, let's turn her over and see what's happening in the back.
- there's nothing at the back there's just...
- No, she's nude.
- Let's leave her be.
- Naked.
OK, bakers, five minute left.
Ahh! Cold, cold, cold.
Come on.
It's falling apart.
In the freezer...quickly.
That is pretty poor looking.
I think I let my glaze thicken too much before I poured it on.
There she goes.
There's a few air pockets in there...
There's a few air pockets down there as well.
OK, bakers, time's up.
Time to take your rolls out of the freezer
and put them on the end of your benches.
It looks fun. It looks ready for a party.
Facing me, I've got a bit of a crack.
It can crack if it's overcooked.
That is stunning.
I mean, really good.
The passion fruit comes through really well,
pineapple holds its own and the sponge is delicious.
That Italian meringue is fantastic, as well, on the top.
If I'd done that, I'd be really proud.
I'd be amazed.
I think it's beautiful.
Quite flat. Have you done layers?
Because I was expecting it to be a bit more domed.
I'm just trying to find the sponge.
Have you got the sponge?
I think that's part of the problem.
The sponge is so thin...
that it's struggling to keep the control
of the ice cream that's inside.
Did you intend to do a Swiss roll?
Yeah, I always want...
Yeah, I didn't realise it was a different type.
The ice cream's all gone.
It was getting pushed out as I rolled it up.
It, sort of... Like a tube of toothpaste, so I tried...
Which is why the idea was to just roll it once,
to keep the ice cream...
- It makes sense now.
- ..inside.
- Nice sponge.
- Nice Swiss roll.
A good sponge, but where's the ice cream?
I know.
I think it looks really most exciting
- and you've done that all freehand. It was your design.
- Yeah.
Your chocolate ice cream is very good
because it masks the coconut.
That strawberry mousse is beautiful
and I think the whole package together...
I think you should be very proud of yourself.
Wow, look at the colour on that.
The flavour's great in the ice cream.
I think the depth of the sponge is good.
The mango lost its way slightly,
the coconut inside is just overwhelming everything
but the Italian meringue on the top is delicious.
Thank you, sir.
It does look a little bit sad.
I know you were trying to show us lots of skills.
As soon as you put the grape jelly
in with the ice cream, it's going to make it run,
and I just wonder whether peanut butter goes with these, we shall see.
The actual sponge itself
is very, very close textured.
That peanut ice cream is fantastic. It is beautiful.
Thank you.
That is lovely.
Quite refreshing...
against the chocolate as well.
The grape actually gives a little bit of...soothing to the peanut.
Although...
it looks like you've dropped it from 10 foot.
SHE LAUGHS
LAUGHTER
I think your lady needs to get a little bit of sunshine to her.
The design of your palm trees
and so forth, I think, is lovely.
See if we can get a slice.
Shall we take the lady off?
Oh, please, no. Paul, no, no!
I won't.
I can't believe you did that.
I think it's excellent.
I think the blend of the mango with the pineapple, with the sponge.
Great proportions altogether,
and finely decorated.
Got that mango absolutely in the middle.
THEY LAUGH
The ginger with the mango and the ice cream,
altogether with the jam and the sponge are...
..ingenious, yeah.
The texture of each component is right
and the flavour is knock-out. Well done.
- Brilliant, thank you.
- Well done.
So, Paul and Mary, one of the most technicolour challenges
we've ever had on Bake Off. How did they do?
I think Nadiya's done well.
I thought the design on the top of her sponge was fantastic.
Altogether, as a package,
very well thought through.
Ian went into today with quite a lot to pull back.
Has he managed to do that?
MARY: He was really right down at the bottom
and today he's lifted himself up
to do something absolutely beautiful.
Ugne has had a bit of a bad day.
The ice cream flavour was pretty good but,
I think, once she thought of putting the grape jam through it...
that was always going to be a problem.
I think Flora's in a little bit of trouble,
the look is great but it's got to taste good.
The whole thing has got to work together.
Are you two clear as to who's done really well and who might be going?
MARY: I've certainly made up my mind,
- I would think we're on the same wavelength.
- I think so.
In which case...
shall we share a torso?
- Yeah.
- What do you want? I might have a leg.
- I'd like a bikini bottom.
- Really?
Bakers, today I get the wonderful job
of announcing Star Baker.
Now, today's Star Baker is terrible.
Terrible at technical challenges
but something rather magical happened.
And instead of being rather terrible, became rather brilliant
to go along with the rest of her brilliant baking.
- Nadiya, congratulations.
- APPLAUSE
Now, this job gets harder every week
as we get to know you and love you and...
..as you know we can take everybody with us into next week's Bake Off,
so the person that were saying goodbye to today is...
Ugne.
- We're so sorry.
- No, it's fine.
We're very, very sorry to say goodbye.
It was a shame to say goodbye to Ugne
because she has potential.
But I think she got carried away of trying to do too much.
She is a fantastic baker at the end of the day
and I do hope she carries on.
She's got some great ideas for flavours
but sometimes she goes a little bit wild.
I will keep working.
I will keep baking, definitely.
Keep experimenting.
Massively dodging the bullet
and that's not a comfortable position to be in.
I'm just feeling hugely relieved more than anything.
Because, yeah, I was...
I had fair reason to feel quite nervous.
This weekend has really taught me
that you've got to fight hard round here. You really have.
- Well done.
- Thank you.
See, I told you.
My kids are going to be really proud.
And my husband's going to be so proud.
They're going to be so proud, I know they are.
It's weird, I'm never proud of myself
but I'm actually really proud of myself.
Next week, pastry.
So difficult to roll. I don't know why.
A shortcrust signature
with a dreaded pitfall...
Ooh, bit of a soggy bottom there.
- A pungent technical...
- SHE RETCHES
..that beats going to the gym...
It's a good little workout, actually.
- ..and the puff pastry Showstopper...
- HE EXHALES
..with more huff than puff.
It's hard to pick. They're all so hideously deformed
Your plums aren't cooked either.